it's time it's time for me to play a
hard real [ __ ] hard game ha Jayesh
and for me to do real extra well I made
sure cuz I'm a pro gamer I'm gonna put
these on my balls
I learned I was supposed to do nipples
but I just changed my mind putting them
on my boss
I realize this is a little weird for me
to do be doing this on camera
oh no oh okay they I will I'm not lying
these are attached to my nuts now if I
die in the game I die in real life I
mean I get electrified on my boss
I'm legit scared oh [ __ ] I don't even
remember how you [ __ ] play boom boom
boom oh my god I almost died already ah
okay I'm still alive somehow boss no
come on we were barely just getting
started okay fine you know what how bad
can it be
[Music]
how man and it really be
how bad I mean come on how bad can it
really be
oh [ __ ]
J sex god damn it I'm not doing that I'm
not doing the boss I'll do it I'll do my
nose boom-boom boom-boom
hell yeah [ __ ] oh so I gotta make the
turns and hit the right points and if I
don't do it right oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
what happened [ __ ] there it is ah ah
come on I see the butthole ah [ __ ] yeah
did it see rank oh this is what a real
gamer looks like [ __ ]
boom boom boom bump bump no no why this
spikes
how does this work cuz sometimes I don't
feel anything and sometimes god dammit
I well I mean it's it's made for the
nipples I just want to be a good gamer
oh yeah [ __ ] Jesus
okay it's working left turn right turn
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what about my neighbors
say thinking proud of Pat let's share
the pain doesn't work does it
[ __ ] jeez sex Peter pride 2016 I think
we're ready for the boss again what if I
do my penis would that be weird
I think the penis is a little too far
okay let's do my ass there we go there
we go it's attached there we go oh we
are we are locked and loaded baby
I never been shocked in the ass before I
really don't want to get shocked in my
butthole
alright come on [ __ ] yeah wait a fellow
Romanian I need you Romania
I need you to taste my ass yes if I die
taste my ass okay okay okay go down you
got to go lower
I won't fart but okay only if I die okay
hey hey careful I don't like that you
got it
hey it's like stop give them to me okay
just put this on my ass thing is this
game Romanians a little bit okay here we
go
don't zap me lest I die okay that's the
rules it's to a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I'm not
dead I'm not dead I'm loss of life don't
you dare this is so distracting Jesus
Christ hey hey what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you don't touch my ass Oh get out
get out okay how about this I'll just
sit on it
I don't need your Romanian bye I think
for me to really truly improve in this
game I need to look at the real masters
how they do it hi baby girl
hi thank you I forget I kept dying you
know well it's not thank you I mean I
love you too grant I was about to say
that every beach in the universe I don't
every planet every galaxy oh thank you
wait what the [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] is
this
twelve million views really so this is
where all my [ __ ] views went Jesus
Christ
oh oh oh now real pissed
shitty b-movie memes I'm taking over my
channel oh my god well I gotta step it
up now [ __ ] you b-movie I'm doing this
for my boyfriend I'm at the top of my
career I'm at the top of my game this is
some quality content I'm sure you're
thinking the same thing you're not gonna
slap my ass tonight not today or any day
for that matter ADHD doesn't feel that
bad in the ass if you think about it cuz
like you have a lot more oh Jesus a
b-movie with that please oh I'm furious
hey youtube where's all my suggested
viewers huh you're all going to [ __ ]
be movie it's that why it's that why all
my views right now are so [ __ ] huh
that's not why my suggest abuse a less
than 1% when they should be 58% it's
that way I lost half my [ __ ] viewers
YouTube for shitty b-movie suggestions
the thing that I built for six years
you're trying to kill my channel YouTube
stop oh my [ __ ] doesn't matter what's
the point of me even being here my
videos are [ __ ] so long they remove
the suggest the [ __ ] used to be 30%
[Music]
suggested videos are 0.2 you know I used
to think it was my shitty content but
it's clear that it's you - please leave
a like so that this video will get
viewers suggested videos if you see this
video in the sidebar please click on it
you - thanks I'm setting it on max
[Music]
Oh
you
[Music]